2017 was a brutal year of celeb losses
from beloved musicians to fan-favorite
actors the year claimed a lot of
high-profile lives
here are some of the biggest celebs we
lost last year
chris cornell soundgarden and audio
slave front man chris cornell's career
spanned three decades
the rocker founded soundgarden in 1984
and the band became one of the most
popular and influential groups in the
burgeoning seattle scene that would come
to define grunge
soundgarden reached the mainstream with
their 1994 album super unknown
which featured the grammy winning
singles black hole son and spoon man
and after the band broke up in 1997
cornell remained in the spotlight with a
string of solo albums and as singer of
the super group
audio slave before soundgarden reunited
in 2010
cornell also contributed to several
movie soundtracks including those for
singles
mission impossible 2 and 12 years a
slave
he received a grammy nomination for his
casino royale theme you know my name
and an emmy nomination for the keeper
from 2011's machine gun creature
unfortunately cornell ended his life by
hanging on may 18th
the 52 year old singer was found in his
hotel room in detroit
shortly after his final concert with
soundgarden ended
sam shepard decorated playwright and
actor sam shepard was the very
definition of a double threat
the winner of 13 obi awards he won his
first six for plays he wrote between
1966
and 1968. he soon made the transition
into screenwriting with films like me
and my brother
then in 1978 he stepped in front of the
camera as a land baron in terrence
malik's days of heaven
he continued to work as a playwright and
pinned his critically acclaimed
family trilogy the first installment of
which would earn him the 1979 pulitzer
prize for drama
but he also thrived as a character actor
at the same time
earning an oscar nomination for playing
chuck yeager in the right stuff
in his later years shepard appeared in
movies like black hawk down
the notebook the assassination of jesse
james by the coward robert ford
midnight special and the netflix series
bloodline
shepard ultimately lost his battle with
als on july 27th at the age of 73
jerry lewis comedy legend jerry lewis
was one of the most recognizable and
influential american entertainers of the
20th century
the actor skyrocketed to fame in the 50s
when he teamed with crooner dean martin
as the comedy duo martin
lewis at the height of their popularity
they dominated nightclubs
radio and the box office after a bitter
split with martin
lewis remained a top grossing movie star
through the mid 60s with classics like
the bellboy and the nutty professor
his screen work continued all the way
until 2016.
lewis also became well known as the
national chairman of the muscular
dystrophy association
hosting the annual labor day telethon
for more than five decades
raising almost 2.5 billion dollars over
the course of his extended tenure
he was nominated for a nobel peace prize
in 1977.
sadly lewis passed away on august 20th
at the age of 91
after succumbing to heart failure harry
dean stanton
prolific character actor harry dean
stanton enjoyed his first major role in
the 1958 western the proud rebel
he also turned in a memorable
performance as a singing convict in the
1967 classic cool hand luke
he was a regular presence on tv for
decades and he gained notoriety for
roles in two-lane blacktop
alien escape from new york and repo man
landing a rare leading role in paris
texas
he later appeared in pretty in pink the
last temptation of christ the green mile
and had a cameo in marvel's the avengers
stanton often collaborated with david
lynch appearing in wild at heart twin
peaks the street story and more
despite his prolific career he remained
humble till the very end
anybody can be an actor i feel anybody
here
everybody in this room everywhere can be
a film actor if you've got a good
director
the curtain closed on the actor's life
and career on september 15th in los
angeles he was 91 chuck lowe
known for his part in martin scorsese's
good fellas actor chuck lowe spent four
years on
active duty as an army major and
remained in the reserves for three
decades
his friendship with robert de niro
opened the door for lowe's first
on-screen appearance in 1982's the king
of comedy
he also acted in other de niro movies
including once upon a time in america
and the mission but he's still best
remembered for playing flamboyant wig
shop owner
maury kessler in goodfellas he later
guest starred in small screen series
like the sopranos and 100 center street
lowe's life came to an end on september
18th at a nursing home in new jersey
he was 89 monty hall
co-creator and host of the game show
let's make a deal monty hall took
leave of the world on september 30th due
to heart failure at the age of 96.
a native of canada his career started in
radio commentary but he became a
television legend when he created his
hit game show
series in 1963. the show featured
contestants who would come to the studio
dressed in crazy costumes in an attempt
to get hall's attention
then they would pick from a hidden prize
or take cash rolled up in hall's jacket
hall would often go off script and
engage in hilarious conversations with
the players
the series eventually moved to abc
running in daytime
and occasionally in prime time for
decades and later ran in syndication
in all hall estimated he hosted more
than 4
700 episodes tom petty
american music history wouldn't be the
same without tom petty and the
heartbreakers
the band rose to fame in the mid 70s and
was inducted into the rock and roll hall
of fame in 2002.
petty was also a member of the 80s
supergroup the traveling wilburys with
bob dylan george harrison roy orbison
and jeff lynn
and he also sold more than 80 million
records worldwide
making him one of the top selling
musicians of all time he also acted
making cameos in films like made in
heaven and opposite kevin costner in the
postman
he also had a recurring voice roll is
lucky on king of the hill
after spending decades in the spotlight
petty's story came to an end on october
2nd
the 66 year old was found unconscious
the night before and was rushed to the
hospital
after his family learned he had no brain
activity they made the decision to
withdraw him from life support
ralphie may a comedian who rose to fame
after appearing on the first season of
last comic standing ralphie may had been
working his way to the top for years
before the world knew his name
he'd previously won a contest to open
for sam kennison when he was 17
which prompted him to pursue comedy as a
career
after working the stand-up circuit for
years he eventually released a series of
comedy specials and dabbled in scripted
acting
tragically may passed on october 6th
from cardiac arrest and after battling
pneumonia for several weeks
roy dotrice after portraying a
pyromancer on game of thrones
actor roy dotrice left this world on
october 16th at the age of 94.
dotrice served in the british royal air
force during world war
ii and was imprisoned in a german pow
camp
he began working as an actor in the 60s
and appeared in films like amadeus and
hellboy 2.
on television he appeared on series like
space 1999
and beauty and the beast in 2000 he won
a tony award for his role in the
broadway revival
of a moon for the misbegotten however
dotrice is perhaps best known for game
of thrones
he was reportedly offered the larger
role of maester pycelle
but had to back out due to health issues
instead he played the head of the
alchemist guild in king's landing
but before that dotrice provided voices
for 224 characters in the audiobook of
the first novel in george rr martin's
series
a song of ice and fire which inspired
game of thrones
he holds the guinness world record for
playing the most characters in an
audiobook performance
brad befanda best known for playing
felix tombs on veronica mars
brad befanda was also a small screen
staple in shows like csi miami
malcolm in the middle even stevens
boston public and days of our lives
the actor perished on november 1st at
the age of 34 after reportedly jumping
from a building in los angeles
a note was found on or near his body
with the names of his parents
and a thank you to people in his life
dela reese
best known for her work in the cbs drama
series touched by an angel
dela reese started singing at an early
age and formed her own gospel group
signing her first record contract in the
50s and topping the charts with don't
you know
in the late 60s she began acting on tv
before launching her own talk show in
1969.
she became the first african american
woman to guest host the tonight show
with johnny carson in 1970
and later appeared on tv series
including chico and the man
and the love boat in 1979 reece suffered
a near-fatal aneurysm that required two
surgeries
but she bounced back and was later
ordained as a minister
she became a household name by playing
roma downey's sarcastic angel boss
tess on touched by an angel which aired
from 1994 to 2003.
reece earned two emmy nominations for
the role and reprised it in the spin-off
promised land the actress passed away on
november 19th at the age of 86.
david cassidy thanks to his role in the
popular musical sitcom the partridge
family david cassidy was also a legend
of the small screen
he grew up as part of a showbiz family
and signed on to play keith partridge on
the partridge family in 1970 alongside
his stepmother shirley jones
the pair were the only cast members on
the show who were actually allowed to
sing
and cassidy performed the theme song
come on get happy which helped launch
his music career
with hit singles including i think i
love you and cherish
cassidy became a multimedia superstar
he went on to make guest appearances on
fantasy island in the love boat
cassidy also performed in the musical
theater scene and headlined several las
vegas shows
his daughter katie cassidy is also an
actress playing
laura lance in the cw's arrow he passed
away from oregon failure on november
21st at the age of 67.
rose marie best known for playing sally
rogers on the dick van dyke show
rosemarie's family announced her passing
on december 28th
the actress began her career as a child
star under the name
baby rose marie and starred on her own
nbc radio show at the age of five
she went on to appear in vaudeville and
had parts in the 1929 short baby rose
marie the child wonder
and the 1933 feature international house
as a teenager marie became a nightclub
singer before returning to radio
in the early 50s she appeared on a few
television variety shows
and in 1961 she was cast as sally rogers
a comedy television writer on the dick
van dyke show
a role which would earn her three emmy
nominations
she was later a fixture on game shows
serving as the upper center square on
hollywood squares for 14 years
and she worked the nightclub circuit and
continued to make appearances on sitcoms
like murphy brown
wings and caroline in the city she was
94 when she finally
said goodbye to the world thanks for
watching
for our tribute to celebrities who
passed away during the first half of the
year
check out this companion video stars
we've sadly lost so far
in 2017
[Music]
you